[Applause]
embiid's got 11 this corner
if he just bullies his way in that's
going to be an offensive foul
and
[Applause]
embiid now hit with a t i don't know if
that was the eject
injection sign or not i think
scott foster just hit embiid with a t
well he came at danilo golinari
well watch the play first it was the
offensive foul right here
okay and then afterward embiid
bumps into galinari
galinari walks away and then beat that's
the push now
dolinari initiated that contact and i'm
sure they're going to look at it but
still that
ball we'll review the altercation
embiid has to be smarter in that
situation because golinari being kicked
out is one thing
and beat you getting kicked out is a
whole different story yeah and just
watching that again and scott foster was
emphatic in his
point but i think he was just pointing
at him not the toss
signal we're sitting up top here at
wells fargo center
and william b left the floor just going
to his regular seat
well you want the best players in the
game and that includes golonari as well
too because
of the show that he's putting on right
now in this first half you want him to
be on the court if you're the hawks
and you don't want anything that could
take him out of the game
lucky right there that he didn't get a
second one especially for scott foster
but i understand that scott knows the
temperament of these players in the
playoffs
and would not be that quick to the
whistle
to call a back-to-back technical figure
a regular season that's probably
automatic
exactly exactly
trying to calm things down these three
officials
do calm it down now galinari and embiid
have been going at it this
is going back a couple of possessions
a lot of grappling going on and salinari
that was on that three-pointer by curry
when those two hit the ground
physical basketball i mean i like
physical basketball when you maintain
your discipline
[Applause]
so embiid will sit down potentially a
double
technical here let's listen in scott
foster a crew chief
explaining to nate mcmillan now
they heat up that right knee
bringing that ball double setting the
foul has been assessed to galilee or
dead ball contact
and dead ball contact too indeed
and it's the dead ball contact meaning
it was the
kind of the shoulder from galinari when
he got up
into the chest of embiid and then embiid
with the response in the push
that's why it's a dead ball double
technical foul
all right so just mark those it matters
later if there are
t's assessed to either one of these
individuals which is an automatic
ejection so embiid will sit it's a heat
pack on that knee which is a good sign
right knee that has that slight meniscus